hey guys it is the tenth of December
today my name is Jess and this is james
bunny telling this year you might
remember when dying light developer
Techland launched a parody of Destiny's
campaign that oft plays to drink redbull
the dlc code tackle and put up their own
fate campaign that offered up rewards
for drinking water not energy drinks
well it appears they've actually made
good on it the developer announced three
pieces of water centric free DLC based
on the original joke players will
receive the Fountain of Youth
exploration based quest water 2 point 0
which is a blueprint for an electrifying
probable weapon and new park or
challenges themed around water the free
h2o e dlc will come as part of dying
light the following and conscious
addition you'll probably want to beef up
your steam account security after this
story because it turns out 77,000
accounts are hacked every month they'll
reveal the mildly terrifying statistic
which marks a two thousand percent
increase in hacking since steam trading
was introduced for years ago valva said
they attempt to remedy stolen item cases
by duplicating them for the people who
lost them but said that that can create
issues in the steam economy when rare
items become more and more common as a
result valve are putting extra security
measures in place since they don't want
to remove trading entirely the new
changes are designed to protect accounts
trading items away without making it
overly difficult to give stuck to your
pals you can check out the specific
changes in our story on site Miley Xbox
boss Phil Spencer said that the xbox one
won't be Microsoft's last console when
asked if Xbox would ever only exist as
an app store front for brand Spencer
told the verge I fully expect that
you'll see another console from us our
best customers are Xbox console
customers and I want to keep those
people engaged both on the xbox one and
anything we might do in the future I'm
one hundred percent committed
at Xbox exaction and love just added
that Microsoft plan to make gaming more
inclusive and said that they're
exploring quote as many ways to make all
of our experiences relevant across all
of our platform as we possibly can you
let me know down in the comments section
what you cared about today and head to
gamespot we've got stories on fable
legends and uncharted towards dialogue
that is everything I have for you today
but do remember to join me same time
tomorrow for the top five stories of the
entire week I will catch you then